[Music]
okay so I will discuss this line of work
showing times best hardness for learning
problems this is a pretty recent line
for and I will cover some results with
face to mega guard you got : Ron rod and
also some results of other people in the
last five years or so so let me start
with within learning model this is the
streaming model this was suggested by
Shamir and standard Valentin wagger
and they wanted to capture what can a
learner with founded memory learn
efficiently so you have a learner the
learner wants to learn some black box F
think of this is some boolean functions
that you only have black box access to
and in fact you have a much more limited
access to so get to see just a stream of
randomly selected examples so you get to
see randomly selected input here in the
output of the black box then you get to
see the next input and output the next
and the important board here is the word
streaming okay so you can go forward in
the stream you cannot go backwards so
the only ways that you can sort of
remember things is if you write it in
your notebook your notebook is sort of
limited so you can write on on top of
your notebook you can erase that right
again
the question is can you efficiently
learn the function
this is a really understanding what can
be learned under bounded memory but
usually when we talk about learning this
black box F is known to be taken from
some class of functions so it's not like
any function it's possible but we know
that in advance if the function is taken
from a concept class and the different
concept of defined different learning
problems so let me mention a few known
examples from the literature so what if
I tell you in advance that the function
is a priority function how can I
characterize the party function so for
each vector X in 0 1 to the to the n
function defined by X thus on input a
simply take the inner product of a and X
ok which is really the same as the sum
over III X I right
so now what what is your goal and when
you're trying to learn this function
you're sort of given random inputs and
outputs of this function and you want to
learn the function or in other words you
want to learn X its equivalent in this
case so we would talk a lot about party
learning in the first part of the talk
and then later we'll see how to
generalize the result to other problems
I'm going to mention some other classes
of concept classes that are interesting
for us so DNF learning is the case where
we know that F is a small size DNF
formula we don't know which small size
in a formula is we want to figure it out
we are the stream of examples in
decision tree learning we know that the
fetus mode by decision tree in Hunter
learning we know that F is the kunta
what is a hunter it's a function that
depends only on L out of the n input
bits for think of L as much smaller than
n but we don't know which input bits are
the one that the matter ok so we need to
figure this out then we need to figure
how the function depends on these input
bits as we'll see the result that we
mentioned will apply to all these
problems
okay so I want to start with this parity
learning problem and to do it more
precisely and I want to say exactly what
we are trying to do so X this vector x
over the string beans you want to the
end defined the function is and this
unknown to the learner the determinant
wants to know X eventually how the
learner tries to learn X is given the
stream of examples a 1 B 1 a 2 B 2 etc
where each a eye is drawn uniformly at
random from all possible strings of
length H B is simply the inner product
of a is X after seeing the stream of
example the learner needs to to learn X
or output X with high probability you
can also talk about we clearly where we
are trying to output like a hypothesis
that is somewhat close to the true
prophecies in this case and in the
models we going to consider the two are
equivalent so once you have a weak
learner your server learner so it's just
what was on there okay so this is
usually when we talk about learning it's
like we first left worst case on the
function so it is with respect the works
have placed over X you can actually
relax it and consider it in the average
case so let's say that X is close and
uniform at random in the beginning and
we just then redo everything as before
then actually the law of man that we
will show is under this model which
which are which are stronger law bonds
okay so before talking about the loved
ones let's figure out first what are the
upper bounds how can we actually learn
parity okay so how can you learn X from
this streem frontal sample the first
time which it comes to mind is Gaussian
elimination right each sample that you
get gives you a linear equation on the
unknown variable x1 up to xn right so so
you know that in my journey that X in a
product with a equals sum B once you
store a order n of this linear equation
with high probability the rank would be
full and then you can just do Gauss
elimination and figure out what X was so
this very simple algorithm takes you
order n samples store them you need
order N squared memory bits then you do
the Gaussian elimination maybe the time
is there and to the Omega but we will
not worry about time we will worry about
the amount of memory bits and the number
of samples so these are the two
complexity measures that we would care
about okay so this looks pretty
efficient at least in terms of samples
it's actually optimal right because we
did this ten samples to get enough
information about X but we can ask maybe
we can improve the memory in fact you
can you can you can learn this with only
linear memory but this requires
exponential time and what is this
algorithm so there are actually two
variants of this algorithm so I will
just grab it let's describe the first
one so I'm going to go over all possible
X's so I've to design of them I will
store my current guess for X and I will
check if my current guess is consistent
with let's say the next and squared
samples okay so for each iteration
whenever I'm trying to check X I'm
drawing fresh samples maybe N squared of
them
we'll have to the anthems and squirt
samples however the amount of memories
that they require is just to store eggs
and store a counter so n plus order log
n so really I can I can well then just
yeah actually you can do it in two to
the N you can okay like the wrong eggs
would on expectation after like a
constant number of attempts would vary
but yeah just want to be on the safe
zone okay another algorithm here is just
to to wait until you see the standard
basis this would also take you to the
same time and when we try you just to
store the evaluation of on the standard
basis which is n bits okay so these are
the two algorithms and you can also set
well these twelve it's a pretty simple
one of them is very good depends on the
number of samples but quadratic mimic
memory does there as linear memory but
explains the samples can we trade off
between the two can we maybe get
something better it for your love and
I'll enter the 1.53 memory bits the
surprising answer is it that we cannot
so so maybe the work trade-off is
problematic because there is no
trade-off in this case yeah there's just
lower bound so one Rises break through
shows that if your algorithm uses less
than N squared memory bits so it
requires to have an exponential number
of samples it so basically what what
does this cure of tell us you have these
two algorithms and there is nothing more
than that to the Omega and it even works
when the amount of memory bits is
smaller than N squared over ten pretty
good constant we don't know exactly what
is the right constant we know that you
can do it in N squared over four number
repeat
and the first part of the talk will be
mainly about how this proof is go and
going on but before going into the proof
I want to mention the error other world
with Gillett : run rods where we focused
on a sub case of disparity learning we
are interested in understanding what
happens if we know in advance that the
vector X is sparse okay so let's say
that the vector X is l1 and all the rest
are zeros
I think of L is much smaller than me and
maybe login so this gives us a lot of
information about text initially and
then we need to figure out text after
things the examples so why do we care
about this special case so it's a very
natural special case many people came up
with this is an open question after
seeing the result of from moreover if l
equals log n ok so if we look look at
this sparsity log n case it's also a
special case of linear size DNF linear
size decision trees and hunters on log
and variables you can see this this is
pretty simple so once you have sparsity
l the input bits that you depend on our
own is the one where X is equals 1 right
1 where X R equals 0 doesn't affect the
output of the function so really when
the parties else parse you only depend
on L variable so your conten and
variables any internal variables can be
described as a decision tree of depth L
or size exponential email so that's why
you get this thing and any decision we
can be tribe as a DNF formula sitting
outside so so that's why you get all
these results all these connections so
what does it mean it means that if you
want to learn vnf formulas you must also
learn sparse parities or in other words
if you have a lower bound for sparse
belicus you have lower bound for
also just again this is something that I
will mention so this was the motivation
for us and then okay again you need to
understand the upper bounds what is
possible so we know a lot about the
little vector X we know that the expires
again we can sort of adapt the
algorithms from from before the general
case so the one one of them was just
going over all possible X's and trying
to verify that you get the right X so
this would be a very similar to what we
had before but now the number of
possible X's is n choose L and again
I've been very cautious here and I
required there to check if this is
consistent with the next n squared
equations how much memory it requires
you to store the current guess for X
well you just need to store L indices so
it's log n chose L or at most L times
Logan right so the memory is really good
here it's even sublinear the number of
samples is not so good right so if l
equals log n it's super polynomial it's
n to the log in you can ask maybe you
can find something better in terms of
number of samples so you can try to do
something similar to Gaussian
elimination
there will be a small twist here so I'm
going to record something like L times
log n equations in my memory and then
I'm going to check which X is consistent
with this set of equations so this thing
is not efficient efficient in terms of
time but we don't care about time we
care only about samples and amount of
memory so why would this work even okay
so think of X how much entropy do you
have on X you have at most L times log n
entropy this is enough anyway but it's
that argument marginal is it just
Occam's razor right yes this is sort of
yeah this is like a comb raises at you
you cannot let please do it with order
log of this number of functions this is
still not an efficient algorithm so it
will be interesting maybe you can say
something about time complexity not only
something okay so what is the sample
complexity what is in memory complexity
here the sample is it's like L Times log
and like super efficient the optimal
thing that you can do the memory
complexity is n times L times log n
right because for each equation we need
to store it which requires us n bits so
this is super linear and this is what I
want to emphasize here so we got here a
very good memory and Superpole no number
of samples here we got very good number
of samples but super linear memory
we were very tempted to to to conjecture
and even at a proof at one point but we
do but these are the only two algorithms
as in the case of learning general
parties maybe if you have less than this
amount of memory then you require this
amount of samples or something like that
this is not true actually
so in the sparse case there is a
trade-off you can find other other
algorithms yes
l squared random blocks and you think of
like summing up the bids in each block
and because you have you know more than
the birthday paradox number of blocks
you expect each X on each a hexagon
that's one to go into separate block you
get the or of the XS in that blog so it
sounds similar to the algorithms that we
found yeah yeah so there is a trade-off
because of the sparsity you can somehow
save something along the lines that
Russell suggested worth okay so so
actually realise the algorithm we
realized to begin the proof and we try
to fix it okay so so you if you are in
system linear memory we could find an
algorithm that runs in L to the L number
of samples and then we ask yourself you
know we found this algorithm maybe there
are others and in particular we were
interested in the case of L equals log n
can you do it with linear memory and
polynomial number of samples okay so
this is what we consider less efficient
in the answer that we gave is that this
is impossible in fact if you insist on
linear memory this algorithm is more or
less tight okay so for learning sparse
parity you need at least n times L to
0.99 memory or at least L to the L
number of samples if your memory is
smaller than that immunity
okay so up at least in this in this
sense if you are only interested in like
linear size memory algorithms then this
fig is optimal so you get L to the homer
order L upper bound yet L to the Omega L
doable but what is this L to the L is
like log in to the log n so it's super
it's actually super polynomial right
it's like something like n to the logo
game okay so in other words what did we
get we get it's the logs log in sparse
case cannot be learning linear memory
and and and the polynomial number of
samples so you easily this could be the
memory to be super linear all the number
of sample to be super polynomial and in
particular we get it for all these DNF
decision trees and hunters okay so
because this is a special case
any questions this is true probably for
any L up to maybe this is true for all
else I don't remember maybe it's true
only for L up to n to the 0.9 and we
have actually the expression here is no
come again so like you could sort of
play with it more so you can even know
if you're like n times L but then this
would be 2 to the L but I don't want to
say 2 to that because those L is
polynomial when l equals log n so you
need to like you have some balance in
it's actually a curve yeah it's not it's
not an efficient
and what they can't equip
Oh what is that something on air for the
elderly good algorithm and there's not
you need to know where in the bathroom
what it whatever see if there is a
constant gonna have constant samples but
you need to then yeah so maybe they are
like additional factors
many times log in but I don't remember
Mary I can check it out they're not a
member of the top of my head
if you think of fellas like it's
something at least like log n over log
okay yes so are there any better
algorithms for learning with DNS or
decision trees which satisfy the lower
vampire better than algorithms that are
better so it cannot be better right well
no no I'm satisfied the lower bound
other positions to be like so fun it's
like you're spacing a little rate for
like say learning at a login right so
okay so it's a very good point this is
one of the open questions so in the case
of sparse parities it seems that our
upper bounds match the lower bounds in
case of DNF learning or decision tree
learning or futon learning the lower
bound is this thing yes it's the same
old one but the upper bound is is not
matching so we don't know how to use we
don't know take this algorithm and the
upper bound is something trivial like
maybe N squared memory beats so there is
a huge gap between the lower bounds
which is only slightly superlinear and
the upper bound on the memory which is
quadratic so this would be interesting
to close this gap and to understand
story
a lot too before going into the proof I
want to mention some of the motivations
for this intubation and application of
this result so okay so we start with the
motivation of learning sorry I would not
repeat it as a motivation come from
cryptography this application is to
bounded storage cryptography so based on
this result you can come up with a very
simple scheme that allows you Alison the
Dow's Alice and Bob to encode to encrypt
and decrypt messages they need to share
a key of length n which may be simply X
and then whenever I want to send a
message to Bob she would sort of draw a
random a take the inner product for fare
next and get from it a random looking
bit an x-ray to ear to our message so we
would require something like n steps per
bit and this would be secure against
attackers that EV less than N squared
memory bits I want to do to do it a
little bit exposing so we have Alison
Bob
and they draw X uniform at random from 0
1 to the end this is their key the the
attacker doesn't know X now whenever I
just want to send some message em think
of a message is just one beat Shiro's a
uniform at random from 0 1 to the end
she computes the inner product of a
the inner product of a with X and then
she sends a and M X or B
now she wants to send a new message m
Prime she does the same thing she grows
a a prime you can't use me Prime and she
sends a diamond and Prime
so if an attacker that just listened to
this conversation can learn X so it
solves a problem of parity learning
because you just get to see like inputs
and outputs this party function and says
this is impossible so if the attacker
has less than N squared bits of memory
it cannot learn X it cannot know the
secret key you cannot even predict let's
say or decrypt the next message so
basically we can repeat these rights as
and so each time we are doing it we're
sending one equation so we can repeat it
at most exponentially number then we
need to maybe exchanger you but I guess
we will not reach this point so the
attacker cannot retrieve the key but is
the scheme secure according to this
definition of the queue so as I
mentioned as I mentioned the attacker is
cannot even weak learn the function so
it cannot even like sort of
equipped with probability better than
let's say 1/2 plus Epsilon look at the
sequence
yeah it's pseudo-random for this okay so
so it's something it's an exception
schemes that like if you think that
there is a gap between the power if you
can do something in time and then that I
don't need to have N squared the amount
of resources so in some sense when
technology grows and but the drawback in
this scheme is that you will need to
perform n operations for a beat that you
want to
so what do we get from this parse case
so we get something a little bit weird
we can decrease the key length actually
to L the the time is still N and the
scheme ISKCON is unconditionally secured
against attackers which memory less them
and intangible as long as the number of
samples is less than let's say L to the
N so this is a bit weird because I mean
the problem was not the key length it
was the fact that we invest a lot of
time so so we want to fix that so
actually in the second part of the talk
we will see that we can do that we can
take the key next to the end and the
time to be L and to be secure against
the same guarantees okay so then you can
just think of L maybe as like a really
large constant
reasonably large memory
when other motivation comes from
complexity so time-space lower bound or
time-space trade-offs were studied in
complexity a lot this is just a partial
list of words the main difference in
this work and the reason that it can get
like a quadratic door bonding the
memories that the model here is
different the only model is sort of a
weaker model of accessing the input
because we are accessing it as if it
were stream so we can only like do a one
pass on the input and instead of just
going back and forth which allows us
more so I will not get into this too
much but I think that Ryan will speak
about some of these resulting is course
on Monday so be very interested to to
hear more about it
okay so now we want to formally define
the model and go to the proof to see how
the proof goes so we're gonna model this
bounded memory learner is a branching
program this is the non uniform way of
capturing budget space computation what
is a branching program it's a layered
graph each layer represents a time step
of the of the algorithm or of the
learner in each layer all these vertices
represent all the possible memory
configurations that the learner could
have
what do we have for each non-leaf we'd
have edges corresponding to how do we
update the memory given the next sample
okay so we would have two to the n plus
one outgoing edges out of each vertex
one correspond to each possible a comma
B case of remember that a was a string
in 0 1 to the N and B was just a beat so
you can think of just the parity
learning problem for now later we would
generalize it to other problems ok once
we draw the sequence or the stream of
examples this selects a sequence of
edges in this in this branching program
which recalls computational tough ok so
simply follow this path until we reach a
vertex in the last layer or a leaf
whether we wanted to do when we reach to
the last vertex we want to output our
guests for X so each vertex V in the
last day I would have a a guess for the
value of x so it'd have a vector X tilde
of V the guess for the value of x and
the problem would be successful if x
equals x tilde of P the problem needs to
learn and as I said you can also relax
this and talk about weak learning but
for this problem and in this model the
two are equivalent so once you get a
function that agrees with your party
function on let's say 90% of the input
you can sort of like decode and find X
the closest party function this is maybe
not time efficient but we are not
talking about time we're talking about
space and samples
so these two are sweeter okay now I want
to mention slightly non-standard poodles
this is a model that run introduced to
solve this problem
this is a model called a fine ranching
program and I'm sorry for the collision
with a B piece it was in Perea and sugar
camp so an affine branching program is a
branching problem with additional
properties so you have the same the same
structure as before but now each vertex
v remembers system of linear equations
okay so for each vertex we would we
would associate the system of linear
equations think of them is like what the
learner remembers about eggs what we
would want off the system of linear
equations we would want them to be sound
you would want that if V is reached by
the computational path and you have
these equations on V then the true
unknown X would satisfy all the
equations so we don't want to just write
equations that we made up we sort of
only want to store equations that we saw
or maybe linear combination of equations
that missile
okay so this is the sanest property but
just to satisfy this it's pretty simple
and did you see how can you satisfy this
property
okay so the first thing is not clear
that actually you can do it for this
program but the second thing that all
program you can just say that well you
remember nothing
and this satisfy the soundness right
every every vertex that you reach
satisfies this equation so see so this
is redundant case we want to somehow
avoid it so we need a definition that
would say that the equations that we
remember actually capture our knowledge
on X okay so we are capturing by this
notion of accurate are fine branching
programs what are these things so look
at these random variables that describe
the vertex reach by the computation and
a path on the if-- layer okay so this is
a random variable and you know in what
randomness it depends it depends on the
randomness of X and on the randomness of
the first I samples okay so
this panel by book we can look at the
distribution of X the condition on the
event that we reach a specific vertex V
so we will look at a specific vertex V
and look at the distribution of x2 this
gave us the distribution of Earth's
strings of length n we would say that an
an event branching program is a great if
for every vertex V this distribution is
close to being the uniform distribution
over all the solution to the equations
so basically the previous solution would
want to also we said that we cannot
associate the empty set this is does not
work because in some cases we remember
something on X this would not be
captured by the so this really tells us
that whatever we remembered about X is a
set of linear equations so this is a
more restricted model of computation
it's not clear whether that you can sort
of convert a branching program to this
model if this is actually the hard part
in the poor statistical distance
and
[Music]
yeah so so what will be is a proof plan
we will start with a bunch of programs
it doesn't necessarily have this
property that it remembers just equation
good to remember anything that will
convert it or simulate it using an F and
branching program to go from the branch
problem to the affine thing we would
need to introduce new nodes and sort of
like increase the width but we will do
it in a controlled way so we will
increase the width but not by too much
then in the second step we will prove
that if you have an event branching
program that solves this particle
learning problem then it requires to be
either very wide or very long white
correspond to having a lot of memory
don't correspond to seeing a lot of
examples okay so this is our proof plan
and so the first step is is trickier one
the second step is isn't it there is a
bit simpler and then in the second part
of the talk we would see how to
generalize it to other domains and then
we would not have this two two-step plan
we would only have the second step
okay so I want to be a bit more precise
so this is very high-level it's this
simulation and then the double bond I'm
gonna make some choice so instead in the
often branching problem that I'm going
to produce I would have some some
threshold K you should think of this
case roughly is a sparsity of the part
of the sparse parties or the linear in N
in the case of general parties and we
will store up to K equations in each
vertex what do we do if we see more than
k question or if we get 2 k questions
and i whenever the learner with
remembers K equations on the input I
declare that it wins does it succeed and
learning and we will show all bands even
under this more relaxed notion of
success you can see that this is
essential like in order to learn X you
must learn at least something like L
equations on X in the oven case
otherwise you have simply too many
possibilities what is the correct value
and you cannot guess it
and also in the general case you need at
least something like order and equations
in order to just have some certainty on
the value of x and there is some
intuition behind this setting so if you
think of like the Gaussian elimination
algorithm when does the memory really
blow up so when you store any question
you just store and these when you start
to you stop something like 2 m we stock
a you store KN bits but then you realize
that you can save a little bit because
you can sort of perform the Gaussian
elimination on the K where K sub matrix
so you're storing something like JM
minus K squared is in K equations when
you reach n you just need to store this
up sort of the day I but not right so
like you perform the Gaussian
elimination so you don't so in the end
so you go from n something like I know
20 - in the end you you reach 2 and
again but in the middle you have
something like constant maybe n is
available
so when you perform this when you save
this equation since it's a point in time
where your memory exploit is actually
when you remember something like n over
two equations or question and this is
what we will try to capture here you try
to say that this is a bottleneck
okay
so let's return to this proof plan we
want to simulate we want to take a
branching program and convert it into an
event branching program how are we going
to do it so we're giving this problem it
doesn't have system of linear equations
so we're gonna convert it layer by layer
so let's convert the first layer this is
simple we don't know nothing about X we
can put the empties the empty set here
we convert the second layer for this
vertex it's all so simple we just
remember this equation right so we can
put here you can say that here we only
remember this equation let's try to
convert this layer here we we see a
problem why if we got to this vertex
from this half we remember two equations
however if we got here from this path we
remembered a different set of two
equations so it's not clear that we can
actually associated with this vertex
like a system of linear equations that
we capture our knowledge our knowledge
is really that we either write from here
or from here and it's a set of different
equations so in this case we would not
be actually able to resolve this in the
way that we resolve this is recently
introduced to vertices so we will split
this vertices into two vertices
okay so in general when we convert the
eye flare we would look at all the of
the verses in this they will look at
each vertex and we will split it into
several vertices we are doing this
splitting we will take all the incoming
edges we will partition them into large
groups for each group associated a
vertex and a set of accurate linear
equations and we do it step by step and
if we do it correctly then eventually we
get a fine yeah of course
if I will just take every edge and
associated with the vertices after like
seeing n samples in my memory would
already be N squared no matter how I
started with so I want to control it I
want to make the the width not increased
by too much yes so I would want to argue
that like I'm speaking each one to the
read parameters that I get into the type
speaking each one to something like 2 to
the order of K squared
not independent of how many the only
real
and don't try to think of cares one so
maybe like paulien
with after iteration of this number is
not so it doesn't go up it doesn't
matter how many edges you have coming in
each vertex would be split into these
many very Trevor takes of this layer I
see yes the previous layer might have
been split many times but the next layer
would still have the same way that
sphere
okay so how do we do this regrouping
this is really the heart of the of the
truth so let's say that we converted
everything up to lay it I minus one so
for each of these vertices we have a set
of linear equations that accurately
capture our knowledge on x given that we
reach to this vertex now we have all
these edges going into this one vertex
so what we want to do is we want to
regroup them so we want to find a large
fraction of them so that we can
associate with some new vertex and
system of linear equations with another
large fraction and other system of
linear equations in another one
how do we do that
so what is the situation that we are at
so recalls it you want the condition
reaching movie would be close to all
possible solution to a system of linear
equations we know it for a con for each
of the incoming get thirty says next
time that we also know it for the edges
so let says that I conditioned on the
fact that I passed through this edge
what do I know about X another you
satisfy the equation in you and all it
satisfies the question on the edge so in
other its eyes but this system of
equation that Lu Union equation on the
edge other than that it's completely
uniform and I'm adding some little
samples arrive so I'm series that
everything so far was completely
accurate like we see no error at all you
see it is beautiful using the X this
condition and passing through this edge
exit is completely uniform overall
solution to this
[Music]
okay our main lemma would be there is a
dichotomy either there exists an
equation that is shared by a lot of
these edges so each edge has its own
system of equations if we have an an
equation that appears in many of them
it's a good thing for the regrouping why
we will just focus on these that there's
a charge equation and now we have one
equation that we know that the
dissatisfied and then we will try to
find other equations by recursion until
we sort of like figure out a nice
description or knowledge on so they all
of them have this equation in their span
yes so let's say that the first bullet
didn't happen maybe each one of them has
like a different equation okay so the
first gives you like a subspace like
this is the second source is like this
is further subsets like this this could
be a situation well it claims that this
situation sent all of them both to the
same vertex you really don't remember
nothing about X so you like a convex
combination of these subspaces that do
not have anything in common to one
another so basically what you did here
like what the branching point did here
is forget everything and then it's
simple to associate with this vertex and
accurate system of equation you would
simply associated with it the empty set
so so if we have this dichotomy and we
sort of understand what what we are
gonna do okay so I want to try to prove
this and before that let's see how does
this implies that they regrouping okay
so once you have this you sort of look
at this dichotomy if you were in step
one you find this an equation and you
sort of just focus on these edges and
you repeat only on this system set of
edges then you maybe find another
equation another question until at some
point you don't find an equation in this
point you are close to being uniform
over
like all possible solution to the
questions that you stored so far and
then you can associated a vertex and a
system of equation this system of
equations ok so this gives you like a
pretty big group of edges that that you
can sort of associate with it the vertex
and the system for equation how do you
do the rest you just repeat on the
remaining ok so you repeat you do it
enough time so that you cover like most
of the probability mass
so he stopped so either it's because you
funky equation and if you have K
equation do somehow say you call it
success what does success mean so if the
if the ABP remembers K equations on X
then I can declare that it's successful
yeah it learned something about next and
I've I think of it is something with
them I I consider as a success and in
other cases you stop because after
collecting some K Prime equations on the
remaining thing you have in poverty and
each time like the fraction of
probability massive or the fraction of
edges that I'm I'm gonna regroup is
something like 2 to the minus K squared
of the total number of edges differ if
you need something like this many times
I'm covering the well the probability
must swell enough when you say many of
the edges that's to the minors
get traction yeah so n right so n is
this length of a single layer it's it's
log sailing
[Music]
one are you waiting the edges by the
probability of yeah yeah yeah exactly
yeah
[Music]
didn't know whether are the are things
going to a unique vertex in minecraft or
select are these vector spaces so I
guess things are still going each input
goes to a unique place in this vertex in
this graph to find by the results of the
equation so so these must the incoming
edges must be nearly just going
and why why this joint actually it will
be nice if all of them are the same
offense us with them like I would
associate before because I don't yeah
I'm not sure but today every every X
goes to a different person yeah and if
the spaces are roughly you know
particular if the setup is the
distribution on X's they go to a certain
vertex is roughly uniform in the
airplane subspace how could the airplane
subspaces intercept
I think there's some information is
maybe it's good to go back that one a
little confused but there was some
information about things that were being
forgotten here is happening on more than
just X so remember that we also the
random course is also involved with the
A's right so like maybe I got like an
equation and then conditions that I
reached is this vertex I actually
learned that this equation volatile mix
maybe if I get caught from a different
vertex I know that another equation
holdin X so it doesn't necessary
describe different X's because it
corresponds to different randomness of
the earth yes I mean intuitively a node
should that doesn't know very much about
X should this conditional distribution
should be yeah very little information
that describes in the computation part
that I can miss think we looked at this
thing
conditional probability of an ex
condition on reaching a specific vertex
but recall that this random verbal also
depends on the samples just look at like
that says it I have this this two layers
so the first layer just during the
equation then let's say the second layer
I'm forgetting everything then I'm like
taking it like this house each each of
them as a sow space but there are not
disjoint this would fall into the second
part of the de cousin
maybe maybe I'm learning like I remember
it two equations and then we get the
same thing but if I see like this
equation person this equation second
here I would see it in different order
so then I can get like the same subspace
twice very simple
I see right even okay so maybe it will
be a good time to take a break because I
want to go to the white boredom and
who's this male Emma yes so let's take a
break and
[Applause]